bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soir les
hôpitaux sont ils prêts à faire face aux
coronavirus la discussion franche
hier à la pitié salpêtrière entre un
médecin et le président de la république
nous rappelle à quel point l'hôpital
souffre dans notre pays dans ces
conditions les soignants ont-ils les
moyens de bien gérer l'épidémie et que
se passe-t-il si beaucoup de médecins
sont placés en quarantaine enfin les
patients sont ils forcément hospitalisés
lorsqu'ils sont contaminés coronavirus
questions autour de l'hôpital c'est
notre grand débat ce soir notre grand
témoin lui nous livrera tous ses bons
conseils pour ralentir au maximum la
contagion et se protéger de ce qu vide
19 avec plus de 3 millions de lecteurs
dans le monde il est le spécialiste
international de l'optimisation de notre
capital santé
l'auteur à succès et le docteur frédéric
saldmann est avec nous ce soir voilà
donc pour le programme sans oublier bien
sûr comme tous les vendredis notre club
de prôner coeur on va refaire la semaine
politique est tous ensemble en chansons
notamment vous savez tout on y va
hashtag sévère n'oubliez pas c'est parti
on
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir frédéric
saldmann bonsoir et chaud et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation on
n'est jamais mieux soigner que par soi
même c'est le titre de votre dernier
best seller c'est déjà un succès sur
amazon et est en librairie c'est chez
plon c'est un petit manuel de de
médecine préventive personnel on peut
dire ça comme ça
pour mieux maîtriser son poids pour bien
dormir pour rester jeune pour garder une
sexualité au top vous dire un mot ce qui
nous a intéressés évidemment ce soir ce
sont vos chapitre sur l'hygiène en ces
temps de gros navires us puisque vous
connaissez aussi bien cette cette
question de la propagation des épidémies
on en parle ce soir avec cette question
en débat les hôpitaux les hôpitaux déjà
en crise sont ils prêts à faire face à
ce nouveau défi
patrick peloux bonsoir vous êtes
urgentistes président de l'association
des médecins urgentistes de france et
vous n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé à la fois sur des
difficultés de l'hôpital mais s'ils ont
des difficultés à venir pour l'hôpital
si notamment en ile de france
l'épidémie se propageait à john tu es
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes député la république en marche des
français d'asie d'océanie et d'europe
orientale ancien médecin consultant en
risques sanitaires et pandémiques claude
rambaud bienvenus vous êtes la
vice-présidente de france aso santé vous
représentez donc les patients les
usagers des services de santé dans notre
pays enfin alex taylor bon soit vous
êtes avec nous ce soir pour nous dire au
fond comment la presse mondiale la
presse européenne regarde ce virus mais
celui qui va nous planter le décor avant
de vous laisser la parole madame
mesdames messieurs c'est stéphane
blakowski si j'ai bien compris le
coronavirus et d'hôpital c'est une crise
dans la crise tout de suite
[Musique]
tout ce soir stéphane installé voir si
j'ai bien c'est la fin de semaine vous
savez si j'ai bien compris ça y est
l'hôpital et deux en retour à la une de
l'actualité jeudi de retour il me semble
me souvenir que l'an dernier il a déjà
été à la une de l'actualité on avait
découvert que manquer de personnel
manquait de moyens le personnel était
épuisé bon et puis on sait ce que c'est
que l'actualité un sujet chasse l'autre
on se dit de façon ça c'est pas des
problèmes on va régler un claquement de
doigts donc on en parlait moins
évidemment avec catherine frot navires
us
l'hôpital est en première ligne pour
combattre l'épidémie et il revient à la
une de l'actualité dont on fait la
jonction entre les deux infos et jeudi
il était déjà en surchauffe
l'an dernier quand il n'y avait rien
spécial là avec l'épidémie c'est le burn
out assuré kim qui nous attend vous nous
avez dit hier et je vous le rappelle que
le patron de l'om est ce nous a avertis
attention nous les médias ne pas
souffler sur les flammes de l'hystérie
c'était son expression
oui vous avez peut-être que burn out est
exagéré encore born art encore on en
parlait déjà l'an dernier mais mieux
vaut peut-être rassuré avant d'inquiéter
donc pour ça je vous propose bien
d'écouter quelqu'un qui va vous rassure
et j'imagine que c'est d'autres
ministres de la santé qui la semaine
dernière annonçait son plan pour faire
face à l'épidémie
70 établissements siège d'un samu seront
activés dès demain pour augmenter nos
capacités de réponse si c'était
nécessaire
de sorte que dès demain tous les
départements de métropole disposeront
d'au moins un centre hospitalier capable
d'accueillir les malades de les prendre
en charge du début à la fin alors myriam
voilà rassurés j'imagine oui enfin de
moyens mais parce que j'ai en tête la
visite du président hier à la
salpêtrière c'était pas très rassurant
alors oui ce temps là j'avoue et myriam
oui j'avoue me dire que le président
avait fait une visite justement pour
rassurer tout le monde pour montrer
qu'il était sur le front bas ont ils
imaginaient écouter un peu les médecins
au champo la tête dernière concernés
c'est vrai quelques poigne et voilà l
affaire était joué le problème c'est
qu'à la salpêtrière il y avait des
médecins qui rêvaient de voir ma peau
depuis un an pour lui parler de plein
plein de trucs et notamment un médecin
du collectif inter hôpital qui en voyant
le président n'a pas pu s'empêcher de
lire ce qu'il avait sur le coeur depuis
un an donc forcément c'est sorti un peu
brutalement on écoute quand il a fallu
sauver notre dame
rébu là il faut sauver l'hôpital public
est en train de flamber à la même
vitesse que d'autres l'âme a failli
flambée ça s'est joué à rien et là en ce
moment ça se joue à rien
j'ai pas d'autres choses à dire ah oui
vous pouvez compter sur nous la paire
sera noir après sa pause non d'accord ok
voilà l'échangé très franc et la mérite
voilà d'exister on sent qu'on peut faire
confiance aux médecins en moins alors on
peut compter sur des médecins est ce
qu'ils auront les moyens pour faire ça
c'est évidemment bien même nous ne
sommes pas en chine et là on a vu que
les chinois eux en dix jours ils
construisent un hôpital donc est ce
qu'on peut faire pareil même en 10 mois
est ce qu'on y arriverait mais il n'y a
pas simplement une question de moyens a
semble-t-il parce que quand bien même on
aurait des moyens aussi important que
les chinois quand bien même on aurait
des moyens presque illimitées et bien si
l'épidémie prend une véritable grande
ampleur ben y'a pas de système
hospitalier qu'ils soient de taille à
l'affronter uniquement à l'hôpital enfin
moi c'est ce que j'ai cru comprendre pas
parler le professeur comme hier au
président simon à 1000 personnes
le système n'aura aucun problème pour
prendre ça en charge mais si c'est un
million de personnes ou 10 millions aux
personnes dans un espace très réduit de
temps là on va avoir de grosses
difficultés à manger
heureusement on en n'est pas amis
personne puisque ce soir on a 42 cas en
tout cas plus de 40 42 pour l'instant on
voit que ça augmente même avec un faible
nombre de cas on voit qu'il ya déjà des
gros problèmes fin entendu parler à
creil à compiègne des hôpitaux qui ont
accueilli des patients contaminés dont
d'ailleurs est décédé tout le personnel
qui a été en contact avec ces patients
eh ben on s'est demandés s'ils sont pas
contaminées dont on les a mis en 14ème
comme on dit et du coup ça fait un
manque de personnel d'hôpital qui manque
déjà de personnel donc je sais bien nous
ne devons pas soufflé sur les flammes de
l'hystérie mais quand même on est un peu
inquiet j'espère que l'on va nous
rassurer ce soir je vais commencer avec
l'urgentiste que vous êtes patrick
peloux c'est vrai que 80 soignants
confiné à l'hôpital creil 117 soignants
confiné à l'hôpital de compiègne
ça nous interpelle ces chiffres là
honnêtement à ce que je vois pas
pourquoi ça vous interpelle parce qu'en
fait on fait notre travail c'est à dire
qu'en fait à partir du moment où il ya
un patient qui est potentiellement
contagieux ce qui était le cas sur la
réanimation de creil
on a fait notre job sans que vous le
sachiez dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi
on a évacué la réanimation de creil et
on a mis les malades dans des chambres
sécurisées
donc ça va être ça veut dire que là je
comprends tout à fait votre votre propos
mais on est tous dans le même bateau là
c'est à dire qu'on suit une épidémie en
temps réel
donc on prend des décisions je suis pas
devin je sais pas ce que ça va donner la
semaine prochaine une des conséquences à
creil sait que la salle d'animation par
exemple des fleurs mais fermez donc un
bassin de population qu'il faut c'est
faux nous arrive à démêler le vrai du
faux niveau parce que vous avez le samu
d'accord qui d'un coup réguler et tous
les malades potentiellement grave qu'il
ya sur ce bassin et ce territoire sont
pris en charge sur les autres et des
animations qui sont sur le secteur c'est
ça le plan blanc une planche et dire
qu'il n'y a pas matière à moi je dis
rien je vaux fille si vous vous posez
des fleurs d'un an mais c'est très
sérieux parce que des gens nous
regardent et on la situation est
vraiment très difficile d'accord et vous
pouvez pas d'un coup dire ah bah il ya
plus de réanimation dans un secteur
c'est faux quand on vous quand on vous
pose c'est pourquoi le plan blanc a été
ouvert dans la région de creil dans
l'oise
s'il n'y a pas assez de médecins parce
que ils sont en quarantaine
oui en manque d'effectif il se passe
quoi sert l hôpital d'anomie goûter leur
voyage je pense qu'on a suffisamment de
boulot avec le principe de réalité
on va pas en rajouter sur des hypothèses
pour les faces pour l'instant sans
l'instant il y a les personnels ont été
isolés ils sont testés d'accord pour pas
qu'ils transmettent à d'autres malades
et les malades sont été isolés et testé
ce qui se passe c'est que tous les
malades maintenant qu'ils sont dans les
réanimations partout en france et qui
présente les détresses respiratoires
aiguës ou des insuffisances cardiaques
sont testés donc on a une vision
grandeur nature à l'instant t
je suis incapable de vous dire ce que ça
va devenir c'est ça une épidémie
d'accord avec toi vous pouvez nous
expliquer parce qu'il ya plusieurs
sujets et il ya les sujets de
urgence on sait que vous allez nous en
parler le service du 15 et débordé mais
mettons d'abord lit le scénario en place
vous avez des symptômes
vous avez de la fièvre vous êtes repéré
comme potentiellement voilà susceptibles
de la voix jc vous appeler n'importe qui
vous appeler le 15
et on vous et on vous considère comme
quelqu'un qui est susceptible d'être
emportée à l'hôpital il se passe quoi à
ce moment là mais il se passe qu'on les
prend en charge
vous avez des filières de dépistage qui
ont été montés avec des parcours très
particulier pour pas que ces malades
repasse par la case départ des urgences
et de la salle datant et ils sont
dépistés ils sont isolés on a les
résultats anglet et les tests sont faits
sur glace à l'hôpital dans tous les
hôpitaux si elle était scolarisée
c'est ce que le bij vient d'annoncer non
parce que au moment donc ça faisait très
évolutif mais au niveau de l'ap-hp à
paris tous les hôpitaux parisiens
peuvent faire les tests a maintenant oui
oui c'était pas le cas il ya quelques
jours maintenant c'est le cas et nous
évoluions c'est nous
nous évoluons et c'était comme ans
preuve nous sommes à la veille de
comprendre on s'adapte la lgv votre
question tout à l'heure est ce qu'on
serait capable de construire un hôpital
comme en chine
la réponse allait non parce que la chine
ils font semblant de ces noms mais par
contre nous avons la possibilité de
réactiver des hôpitaux qui ont été
fermés d'accord et notamment à kandahar
à free qui s'appelle l'hôtel dieu où les
chambres et c'est bon elle soit elles
seront pas tellement bien pattes ça
c'est sûr et c'est mais on a des
capacités pour redynamiser ce qui a pas
un moment où plutôt que de déplacer les
patients l'hôpital
en les regardant chez eux on ne peut pas
les soigner chez eux alors jusqu'à sa
sas etc
actuellement chaque jour on définit une
stratégie qui est évolutive d'accord
pour l'instant vous le rappeliez les cas
et les foyers qui naissent un petit peu
partout en france comme ça qui arrive on
les repère on les isole on voit et on
surveille comment ça évolue
pour l'instant il n'y a pas à changer le
scénario
maintenant moi je suis pas adepte des
savanes scénario de science-fiction mais
je sais bien ce que ça ça vous titille
donc d'un coup on serait sûr un
emballement comme comme a dit le
professeur
on change ray en fait on dirait voilà on
fini les patients qui sont malades mais
pas grave ils restent chez eux
d'accord ou sans facteurs de comorbidité
graves comme les insuffisances
respiratoires et cardiaques d'accord ou
déficit immunitaire bon les autres
seront pris en charge à l'hôpital
d'accord il est cas les plus graves qui
seront un tube et ventilés et qui
n'iront pas bien seront mis dans les
réanimations à cordes ou alors donc ça
ça se décidera quand on sais je sais
c'est cette descente dans les fictions
évolution paradoxale pour dire
qu'aujourd'hui c'est simple aux
questions aujourd'hui pour bien
comprendre tous les patients contaminés
au courant des virus sont hospitalisés
alors on se parle là aujourd'hui
non pas forcément mais pas forcément
encore intrigue forcément fed ont fait
le trait à sur la base de la force - et
et mais on fait le tri en fonction de la
gravité et au cas par cas d'accord il ça
cette décision là elle appartient aux
personnels hospitaliers ou c oui c'est
sur place dans un hôpital condé si nous
avons très vite et nous recevons des
algorithmes qui sont validées par la
direction générale de la santé et on les
applique donc alors le moment vous dit
tout va très bien à l'original on est
soigné
vous voulez tout va pas très bien vous
laisser positive mais alors on y va
alors à l'ol et la tristesse leur talent
pour l'instant le sujet semble maîtrisée
dans les heures qui viennent
je peux pas vous garantir qu'ils aient
pas un foyer qui apparaissent à nice
d'accord ou qu'il n'y ait pas un foyer
qui apparaissent ailleurs ou dans le
nord et c'est là on cherche vraiment
avec beaucoup d'intérêt pourquoi ces cas
sont apparus à creil a priori ce qui
semble se dessiner c'est qu'en fait il
ya une base aérienne à creil et que le
virus serait pas c'est parce que l'avion
aurait transité à partir de chine y sera
et la voilà comment cette base militaire
basile de la vie aurait récupéré les
notamment leur ans aide de chine et de
la région de roanne qui ont été rappelés
vous confirmer ça cet avion est passé
par là mais en tout cas ce que explique
le dr pelouse c'est que dans des
situations comme celle là il faut être
très agile et calme en soit les
algorithmes on les applique une nouvelle
à nouvel élément de l'algorithme qui est
envoyé ce matin c'est vrai que c'est ces
lampes à l'échéance de décisions c'est à
dire on pose des questions
le patient répond à tel et tel critère
il va sur cette branche la décision il
répond à tel ou tel critère est bas sur
cette branche là donc en gros on va le
laisser à la maison on lui dit complexe
pour les gens qui dessinaient des
algorithmes c'est au niveau de la
direction générale de la santé s'est
basée alors vous avez une des réunions
qui ont lieu à peu près tous les jours
tous les deux jours avec des virologues
des épidémiologistes des chercheurs vous
avez des gens qui lisent mais vraiment
la ligne près tout ce qui se fait dans
la littérature actuellement et ont tout
ça c'est décidé on dit voilà ce qu'on
applique mais ce qu'on applique ce soir
pas changé mais ça peut changer cette
règle l'air c'est pour ça qu'ils veulent
après le temps justement et je peux vous
garantir cette séquence questions
réponses pour le 10/10/10 aussi bien
deux choses à la crise de l'hôpital etc
donc j'étais venu ici parler et la crise
sanitaire que l'on traverse
et tous les médecins bien avec ce que
cela casse a dit au président de la
république
c'est ce que voulait donner comme
message c'est que vous mettez de côté et
que malgré la crise de longue date que
vous traversez tout sera fait pour que
tout soit bien gérée au maximum je me
dis que j'ai vu les heures
supplémentaires qu'on se tape je veux
vous dire que oui c'est en se mobilisant
est très bien défendre et représenter
les usagers 138 hôpitaux désignés pour
recevoir les malades de 100 millions de
masques supplémentaires
ça c'est le dispositif qui a été annoncé
par le premier ministre par ministre de
la santé vous avez confiance dans notre
système de santé
dans cette période un goûter comme dit
je suis pollue tout à l'heure on ne sait
absolument pas ce qui va se passer
donc on va voir au jour le jour et
s'adapter la confiance elle doit
s'établir sur une forme de transparence
déjà
donc est-ce qu'on a les outils pour ça
ça c'est une question on sait pas
forcément tout ce qui se passe et la
transparence et le choix du gouvernement
un cui où les jours justement explique
cette situation qui évolue les choix du
gouvernement va lui le choix du
gouvernement l on les connaît les choix
du gouvernement c'est le minimum de
confinement donc c'est un choix de la
france qui dans ce choix plus économique
que de santé publique puisque on a quand
même des pays comme le japon l'italie où
là
recchi ont fait d'autres choix ils sont
pas forcément plus idiot que nous donc
on peut se poser des questions là-dessus
quels sont vos questions quand vous
dites plus économique que de santé
publique ou si ce n'est le toit près
l'oms et le confinement a forcément une
portée économique importante
ça c'est évident donc c'est un toc ou un
choix on pourrait dire un pari qui la
voient l'avenir vous pensez ou vous
accusez ne pense pas non non je
regardais un choix et j'entends bien ce
qu'a dit monsieur pelous et c'est au cas
par cas et on voit petit à petit
maintenant si on veut vraiment recréer
la confiance dans la population c'est
avoir une bonne anticipation
il ya des anticipations qui pourrait se
faire on est en train de parler de d
accueil de première intention
essentiellement c'est à dire le patient
qui vient pour la première fois parce
qu'il a un doute il a des signes
cliniques soit parce qu'il est passé par
centre 15 pas soit par le 0 800 il faut
pas oublier qu'il ya aussi un numéro qui
est maintenant ouvert 24 heures sur 24
dans le ministère pour ces questions là
donc ils arrivent et il va être examiné
cliniquement
donc là on pourrait faire comme on fait
le choix d italie les italiens par
exemple les italiens ont créé des tentes
médical qui viennent sûrement d'ailleurs
des stocks militaires parce que ils sont
équipés pour ça ils sont hors les murs
de l'hôpital fann entre les patients de
l'hôpital qui ne sont pas là pour ça du
tout parce que l'hôpital continue sa vie
quand même et les patients qui viennent
qui peuvent être vous n'avez pas
auditifs
non pas du tout sur la question du
confinement vous vous envisagez de
confiner des quartiers je pense que au
moins vous voyez par exemple on a un
exemple on va parler concret sur creil
et sur compiègne ils ont confiné
ils ont demandé au confinement pour les
personnels qui avaient été en contact ou
qui officiellement pourrait être en
contact on pourrait aussi confiné les
enfants on sait que les enfants sur une
population bien particulière là dedans
par lesquelles passe qu'on peut pas
gérer la vache de marc veut pas gérer
les ports de mass konpa j'irai un
certain nombre de choses sont des
éléments essentiels regardez le japon
ils ont fermé leur école ce matin c'est
le voit la rondelle jeanne milan aussi
milan ils sont pas particulièrement
exposés ils ont aussi à cette décision
donc voilà il ya peut-être de
l'anticipation je pourrais jambes c'est
un petit peu le maître pour là encore il
faut faire de la pédagogie
vous allez répondre sur les choix de
santé parce qu'il ya des inquiétudes et
les associations les
les relais frédéric saldmann qu'est ce
qu'on sait sur des enfants parce que on
peut lire ici ou là que ce virus
enfin des enfants ils résistent très
bien sinon il n'y a pas de cas dans
aucun aucun mot n'a donc aucun le cas
d'enfants cac 40
c'est important aucun cas aucun cas
recensés ce qui est une bonne nouvelle
puisque on n'a rien de ce que ça veut
dire que fermer des écoles ça ne servira
pas s'ils peuvent en fait il ya une
chose c'est là je rejoins mon collègue
il ya des choses qu'on sait pas ça
navigue à vue
on sait pas du tout si demain il ya des
enfants tout est possible pour l'instant
il y en a pas et tant mieux
l'adjointe est qu'est-ce que vous
répondez aux associations il ya des
questions qui se posent au fond ou
jusqu'où le principe de précaution c'est
cette question là alors je crois surtout
quand il est difficile de comparer un
pays un autre chacun sa culture et son
contexte dans lequel le virus est apparu
et que ce qui s'est passé au japon en
corée par exemple en corée c'était une
église une forme d'église de mouvements
mouvement religieux qui dans lequel cet
appariement premier donc on n'est pas
dans le même contexte et je crois qu'il
est important dans ces moments là quand
on perd il a rappelé les réunions
interministérielles qui ont lieu le
point qui a lieu tous les jours les
experts qui sont présents dans il faut
absolument faire confiance vous
n'imaginez on les voit on prenait une
leçon de goût de monde dit la culture
explique les choix de mes biens sublimer
quand même mais pas celle à les emmener
non non on n arrête de nous lancer on
est dans quelque chose de nouveau
on ne parle pas d'une varicelle d'une
rougeole ou d'une grippe saisonnière
qu'on sait parfaitement avoir étudié
depuis longtemps on est dans quelque
chose de nouveau qui chaque jour fait
qu'aujourd'hui ce que nous savons ce
sera peut-être balayé demain mais pour
vous être un jeune mosellan blues
seraient simplement pourquoi après tout
entre les ailes italiens et les français
c'est elle c'est l'europe c'est pas trés
culture des il décide de confiner le
nombre d'analystes ont été ici la
lombardie pourquoi la ville de creil ne
l'est pas alors pourquoi on ne le fait
pas alors d'abord sur l'italie en fait
c'est un système de santé différent du
nôtre d'accord qui a été malmené par les
époques de berlusconi quand berlusconi a
fait des coupes sombres sur l'hôpital
public sur la santé publique et sera
donc l'italie
c'est un pays à 6h09 amis c'est à la
frontière de la france etc
mais c'est d'autres cultures leur choix
a été un choix à l'emporte-pièce à mon
avis d'un coup ils ont été débordés ils
savent pertinemment que justement ils
ont tout un système de santé publique
est très défaillant vous avez près de 60
millions de personnes qui passent aux
urgences chaque année tellement c'est
difficile de se soigner là bas c'est
terrible la réussite nous on est on est
on est on est à 21 millions c'est déjà
la scène donc voilà c'est le thème
différent est en effet ils ont pris des
décisions parce que en effet être comme
disait madame en fait il ya la
population a besoin d'être assurés
d'accord donc entre dire qu'on mer un
système quasiment sur mesure comme on a
fait choisi en france en disant voilà on
va cibler on voit au jour le jour et un
système qui est beaucoup plus visible
mais qui en fait on n'est même pas sûr
que ça donne quelque chose de
confinement parce que confiné des gens
c'est bien joli comme mot mais ça veut
dire que vous enfermer des gens
voulaient fait manger comment ils
boivent comment comment il soigne que
ses loyers au delà du truc économie
c'est très compliqué ce qui fait que la
police italienne est en train de courir
après ceux qui veulent se tirer de la
quarantaine parce qu'ils en ont
ras-le-bol et parce que la vie devient
très difficile donc d'un coup il faut
modéliser autre chose et ses cultures là
c'est encore différent en asie sur le
plan symbolique les villes en
quarantaine on n'a pas connu ça m'a dans
ma carrière de médecin j'ai jamais
entendue en 1350 et à la peste noire
là on met des villes en quarantaine ça
démarre en chine puis en italie puis en
france 30 à 50 % de la population
mondiale va disparaître donc
effectivement le notion de 40 m à
l'efficace le remet un moment donné vers
le très très peur très peur de la peste
c'est la peste pour prendre les
archétypes c'est d'un seul coup une
angoisse mondiale colossal mais
simplement la symbolique italienne des
villes en quarantaine on se dit mon sens
c'est là bien mais je jeu mais je
comprends tout à fait mais demain il en
quarantaine et m ou regarder sur les
populations qui sont comment on
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors à créer à
creil il faudrait pas alors en crèche
voilà tout alors après je dis simplement
à l'arrêt dans des groupes tous
voilà comme on dit tous les groupes tous
ceux qui étaient à risque ou question
contact avec les malades de la
réanimation ont tous été dépistés sont
tous surveillés sont tous isolés je
préfère le mot isolement que quarantaine
parce que ça veut confiner voilà ils
sont isolés chez eux ils portent un
masque et settat et tout le monde est
surveillé par lui mais que tu as la
personne intéressant parce que j'ai
manqué ma dame tout à l'heure vous avez
refusé de serrer la main
oui non c'est quelque chose qui
m'interpelle qu'on vote annoncé l'ap à
la main pour le ministre le premier nous
avons pas à l'appliquer je suis venu
tout lui-même
moi je veux vous dire beaucoup c'est
très simple pasteur ne serait que jamais
la maggia effectivement quand en france
y est la gastro entérite la moitié du
pays se retrouve sur le pot parce qu'une
personne sur deux qui sort des toilettes
sans savez les matri qui serre la main
de l'autre comme une personne en moyenne
mais deux fois par les mains à la bouche
masques étaient dans la main de la
voulons retourner dans votre bouche et
là on voit là c'est encore pire en ce
moment la bise c'est encore pire quand
des gens qui savaient la narration la
voisine a montré des choses formidables
tout à l'heure on peut se dire bonjour
autrement alors en thaïlande montrer
c'est comme ça au japon comme cela enfin
pas comme un canard mais presque pour
les femmes c'est différent j'ai les
mains sur le ca est en iran la matière
redire à la main sur le high des anglais
le hawk des américains ils se touchent
pas ils sont même fiers de notre vie on
va se refaire la ville le jour ou
l'autre mais je sais faire la bise à la
masse et et parce que on se repasse l'a
fait justement je vous propose tout de
suite parce que c'est là que j'ai besoin
de vos lumières de démêler un peu le
vrai du faux avec une série de questions
c'est clément pernot qui s'y colle et on
se reparle juste après
le corona virus se transmet par l'air il
se transmet par l'air mais sur une
portée qui n'excède pas 1 m il peut
aussi se propager par contact entre deux
personnes ou via un objet comme une
poignée de porte se laver les mains
protège c'est le meilleur geste pour se
protéger se laver les mains plusieurs
fois par jour au savon ou avec un gel
antibactérien conseil prenez le temps de
bien laver au moins 20 secondes est
fermée toujours le robinet avant de vous
être essuyé en quarantaine
on peut sortir même avec un masque un
patient en quarantaine ne peut pas
quitter son confinement
le vaccin contre la grippe protège le
vaccin contre la grippe n'a absolument
aucun effet sur le coronavirus ce sont
deux virus différents
les masques ne servent à rien les
masques protège bien du virus mais il
faut qu'il soit filtrants et attention
la plupart ne sont efficaces que pour
une durée de trois heures les masques
chirurgicaux et ne protège pas mais
évite la propagation
il ne faut les porter que si vous avez
des symptômes potentiellement inquiétant
on peut recevoir des colis de chine
recevoir ces collines ne présentent pas
de danger étant donné les délais
d'acheminement le virus ne survit pas
plus de quelques heures sur un objet un
vaccin a été trouvée mettre au point un
vaccin prend du temps et demande de
nombreux tests mais des études ont été
lancées et des chercheurs du monde
entier sont au travail
voilà frédéric saldmann dans votre livre
il ya tout un chapitre consacré à
l'hygiène vous parlez des réservoirs
cacher des microbes qui déclenche les
maladies quels sont vos conseils
pratiques aux pratiques dans cette
période est ce qu'on peut se booster un
peu l'immunité pour prévenir le virus
alors effectivement parce que je reviens
sur pasteur il ya le le germe n'est rien
le terrain et tout effectivement
l'immunité joue plus on avance en âge
plus notre immunité diminue donc
effectivement mais c'est bien de la
montée mais il n'y a pas de médicaments
alors comment on peut monter son
immunité il ya comme une bonne piste
je pense que vous savez on n'est pas
sorti de l'auberge avec les épidémies ya
celle ci il y en aura d'autres donc
c'est notre mode de vie sur le qu'il
faut repenser alors moi je vous donnais
conseils que vous mettrez en pratique
dès ce soir
un président premier point avec l'
ordonnance qui va avec
avec l' ordonnance exercices physiques
tous les jours 30 minutes d'exercice
physique par jour sans s'arrêter
d'abord sa baisse de 40% cancer
alzheimer maladies cardiovasculaires
mais montrent l'immunité
donc tous les jours attention ces
quotidiens l'efficacité il ya une étude
qui est sorti qui montrent qu'on libère
1004 molécules protectrice que ça monte
au niveau immunitaire mais ça dure que
24 heures donc d'être quand on fait tous
ceux qui sont en très bonne santé
physique
en plus moi je suis écouté il ya plein
de choses
c'est notre en fait notre bouclier qui
va juste et des vitamines en ce moment à
la pharmacie non non non c'est plutôt
épicé dans la dans l'air que vous allez
comme dim complexe exercice
c'est vrai il est plus raisonnable des
quelques 500 villes et des travaux de la
nobel japonais il ya deux ans qui a
montré que justement le jeune
séquentielle augmente l immunité en
demandant ce qu'il appelait l'autophagie
c'est une façon d'éliminer c'est le mal
formés malades ou mortes et pour à
partiel ces tôles et combien la
séquentielle sais comment c'est pendant
14 heures minimum mais 16 heures ça
commence à monter
vous arrêtez de manger vous buvez de
l'eau des tisanes du thé sans sucre sans
édulcorants et en fait ce jeûne
séquentiel c'est quelque chose d'assez
étonnant parce que ça va donc monter
votre immunité bc l'inflammation
ça augmente aussi l'hormone de
croissance il ya 3000 pour sens une
hormone anti vieillissement et en plus
une autre hormone au niveau bdnf qui
fait qu'on pense plus rapide en une
meilleure humeur en fait vous savez
manche et c'est pas rien c'est faire
travailler le foie les reins une dizaine
d'organes des hormones des enzymes c'est
tout un bazar
il faut laisser au corps le temps de
récupérer vous savez aujourd'hui en
france
on meurt pas vraiment de faim ou de
carence meurt beaucoup d'excès à chaque
seconde on produit 20 millions de
cellules pour remplacer nos cellules
useo morte
le restaurant de copies augmente avec
l'âge donnant lieu par exemple à des
cancers mais quand on fait ce jeûne ciel
renforce son adn il ya moins d'un an de
copies d'air toutes les religions du
monde depuis le début de l'humanité
parle du jeune comme un message du fond
de la nuit donc elle toute une série de
choses qu'on peut faire pour faire
barrière
déjà je sais si c'est très intéressant
ce que dit mon confrère et je pense que
c'est il ya vraiment de bonnes choses
notamment sur le sport mais quand vous
voyez la catastrophe de santé publique
que c'est avec les jeunes qui ne font
plus de sport ceux qui lavent du sucre
et qui conditionne en mettant des vies
c'est terrible alors si on revient quand
même à l'épidémie qui est là je voudrais
juste à vous savoir se laver les mains
on le savait les mains bon c'est
important de mon avis derrière ça
m'énerve parce qu'il ya plein de gens
qui utilisent des gels hydroalcooliques
comme ici ce bénissait les mains ça sert
à rien du tout of pop ou souffle sous le
nom une vraie technique pour laver les
mains ça doit être sérieux c'est un vrai
geste dont l'huile de coude ça marche
très bien
vous prenez gels hydro alcooliques ou du
savon et ben on s'abonne les espaces
interdigitaux parce qu'ils adorent se
mettent en dessous ensuite on se brosse
bien les poignets et sous les ongles
vous savez autrefois il y avait toujours
des petites brosses près des lavabos et
bien faut se brosser les ongles au moins
tous les soirs avant d'aller se coucher
prenez une brosse à dents mais pas la
même que pour les dents pour eux c'est
bien on sous les eaux à ses docteurs et
également les bijoux des études sont
sortis sur les bracelets bagues sous les
alliances on a on a fait les travaux
sous les seins sont énormément de textes
un taudis et art parce que je déteste je
regarde mon alliance différemment vie
les bracelets porte bonheur en tissu
alors là c'est un vrai cauchemar
donc il faut bien se laver les mains
avoir plein un autre exemple qui
ajournerait plein
j'ai pas le temps de tout ça avant de se
mettre les doigts dans le nez
la robe les mains parce que sinon les
virus vous les mettez directement dans
le nez quand se frotter les yeux aussi
oui protée les yeux baissés en pet
l'hygiène c'est très difficile à
contrôler les enfants se frottent
beaucoup l'aimer mais des mre député moi
j'entends tous et tous ses conseils mais
on va pas changer notre façon de faire
cracher le jour le moment on est déjà
mais quand vous voyez des tarifs des
toilettes dans les restaurants dans mes
pensées
c'est le moment où là les députés
auraient tout intérêt à réglementer
quand vous allez en effet pas ce qu'on
peut dire les gens se lave pas les mains
mais quand tu vois les tares halal était
d'accord mais les mains des mutins
témoin pour pour comprendre un petit peu
parce que vous êtes un peu là aussi pour
relayer un certain nombre de questions
voire d'inquiétude des usagers des
réseaux dans des hôpitaux pch chose
comment vous vous qualifiez la manière
dont le gouvernement gère des
chaussettes transparence c'est le numéro
il ya énormément de conseils qui sont
donnés les médias relais il faut le
boulot je pense qu'il faut ou non oui je
pense et un effort énorme et comme le
disait tu peux louer je suis d'accord
c'est quand je dis tout parle tout à
l'heure je parlais des choix les choix
ont été faits le ministre ait choisi pas
tout seul il a toute une équipe autour
de lui
c'est vraiment des choix qui sont faits
avec des experts il ya voilà donc en
avance au jour le jour et en apprend
tous les jours alors justement si on
avance au jour le jour il faut essayer
de trier de faire en sorte que les gens
ne paniquent pas or depuis la crise
italienne
les urgences explose c'est ça les
urgences et les nus mais et le numéro du
samu c'est surtout les numéros du siamu
en novembre et non pour cent on a battu
un record dans la législature le record
du samu de paris dans la nuit de mardi à
mercredi à jeudi avec 4400 appel
d'accord faut se les farcir la wii est
alors le problème qu'il y assez quoi
lasser qui en fait tout le monde appelle
et vous avez des gens qui sont mis en
attente sur le disque d'appel ce qui
nous affole nous c'est que quand vous
avez 26 appel en attente dans les 26
appelle ça se trouve ya comme disait
madame un infarctus une embolie
pulmonaire un polytraumatisé
mais alors et voilà le problème je sais
que tu vas prendre quelqu'un au
téléphone qui va te raconter sa vie
forcément formidable et qu'il est un peu
enrhumé qu'il a mangé une pizza
italienne et peut-être lui et peut-être
qu'il a eue coronavirus et pendant ce
temps-là talent infarctus qui attend il
donc vous allez on aurait pu même héros
spacek ils l'ont flers et le 0 800 jeux
130 000 la ville
ils ont lancé donc ça c'est pas venu
mais en informations c'est au sénat
romain et moi c'est les lundis mérigots
médecins étaient des fans bah c'est des
gens qui applique la gamme de qu'elles
ont été formés qui ont été formés qui
peuvent basculer après sur le cas car
évidemment mais il ya beaucoup pour pour
des s'il s'agit de rassurer les gens
quand ils vous appellent ses taux à zéro
parce que là est la personne au
téléphone vous dira écoutez puisque vous
avez 38,5 des frissons que vous tous et
appelait donc le 15 il vaut mieux le
faire dans ce sens là donc d'appeler le
15 parce qu'on a un corps au pied enfin
mais comme il dit et j'aimerais
j'aimerais vous entendre comme ça
pour revenir à notre débat vont
l'écouter alex il ya quand même cette
crise qui est là depuis l'hôpital depuis
un bon moment oui dans quel état
d'esprit ils abordent cette épidémie là
vous avez dit on ne va pas regarder sur
nos heures sup mais quand y'a un
problème d'effectif à l'ouïe fine art et
ses taux mais comment on fait mais tout
est de trouver mais chère madame
ne serait-ce que c'est une question très
juste est vraiment importante
je vais vous prendre un autre exemple
quand il ya eu l'attentât du 13 novembre
d'accord les attentats commence vers
20h30 21h d'accord sans qu'on demande à
aucun membre du personnel de revenir
tout le monde est revenu travailler on a
rouvert 80 blocs opératoires équipe
complète
vous n'avez pas un système au monde qui
est capable d'avoir un truc comme ça et
on a sauvé toutes les personnes qui
rentrent d'accord bon en fait quand il
ya une crise vous avez ce personnel qui
est vaillant dans son ensemble qu'on a
vu interpeller le président de la
république qui est présent à kehl a donc
vous pouvez avoir un domaine qui s'est
lui même sa rivale même parce que on se
souvient dans ce paris 1 et bien sûr du
retour le vois je le vois au samu de
paris là tout le monde où on a repris
des plages horaires de travail déjà
qu'on en peut plus mais pour aller on a
on a tout repris le seul truc que moi je
souhaiterais
ce clip c'est pas l'heure de la
polémique il faut vraiment défendre le
pays qui est en quelque sorte attaqué
par le par le virus donc faut qu'on soit
tous quand même d'accord mais ça
n'enlève pas en effet toutes ces
revendications qui pour moi sont des
revendications justes sur le fait qu'on
ne donne pas assez de moyens sur
l'hôpital public on paye insuffisamment
les infirmières et le budget qui est
votée par l'ondam par les députés est
insuffisant en fait confiance au
président macron qui a dit c'est aulas
hier l'euro l'orgue à la quand le pays
est dans une situation de crise ou de
pandémie qui arrive on fait toujours
confiance au président madame la députée
genetet et si cette crise du coronavirus
permettait enfin de résoudre la crise de
l'hôpital public coûte on n'en est pas
là pour le moment au contenu de ce qui
nous arrive enfin le jour veillons à
gilles et on verra mais si c'était au
fond vraiment la fenêtre d'opportunité
pour entendre ce cri d'alarmé là mon
avis c'est d'abord ya des moyens qui ont
été mis peut-être insuffisant je
l'entends tout à fait mais pour le
moment avançons et répondant aux
questions qui nous sont posées aux
situations qui nous sont posées c'est ça
aujourd'hui c'est là on a la chance
monsieur peu lula dit vraiment je
voudrais saluer effectivement d'avoir
des équipes de médecins d'infirmières
d'aides-soignantes et s'équipent
hospital dans leur ensemble et
administratifs aux siens qui ont un rôle
à jouer jeux qui sont exceptionnels
il faut le dire vraiment en france
exceptionnel - qui vit à l'étranger qui
suis confronté à d'autres systèmes de
santé je peux vous confirmer qu'on a un
système exceptionnel d'un joueur qu'il
était saluée par l'organisation mondiale
de la santé comme l'un des meilleurs
romans je crois après des états unis est
vraiment il faut le souligner c'est vrai
il faut lui faire confiance
vous êtes rassurés madame rambo oui je
le voudrais renchérir ce que dit
monsieur pelouse c'est à dire que non
seulement il ya les professionnels qui
sont en activité qui sont prêts à
revenir de nos coups de main mais il ya
aussi des volontaires qui sont plus en
activité pour des raisons diverses qui
sont prêts à venir renforcer les équipes
ou camille et de l'épuisement
professionnel et d'exclusion parce que
justement contamination vous avez
parfaitement raison madame
en effet il ya des médecins retraités
par des associations qui viennent aider
les infirmiers psy parce que bien
souvent ils ont ils ont une humanité au
point d'effondrement quand on est ne le
nez dans le guidon on a un peu oublié
d'accord deuxième manche
je profite de votre marque pour saluer
le travail qui sont faits et la
mobilisation qui est faite par les
associations de secours estime
croix-rouge protection 6
l'ordre de malte et c'est parce qu'en
effet tout le monde vient vient
renforcer
mais s'ils voulaient pour faire suite à
ce que vous dites madame la députée
c'est que il faut pas que le politique
là on va jouer la partie on est tous
dans le même sens mon travail etc
il n'y a pas de problème on est
solidaire on est tous derrière le chef
etc
d'accord faut pas l'oublier après
l'annoncé de la dire qu'après faut pas
nous la jouer n'avez vous savez ce qui
compte le plus c'est l'économie parce
que quand on vous dit qu'on manque de
lits commun de moyens j'étais hier soir
pour éviter la fermeture de l'hôpital de
dourdan en essonne qui est un hôpital de
proximité etc
voilà c'est là où vous attend c'est là
on a besoin de dire oui vous avez raison
on a un très bon système vous me lisez
comme de pays souffrent et bien vous à
l'entente des labels il est passé et
vous avez au four l'intérêt un grand
débat social mais j'ai bien entendu je
l'entends suffisamment la part de mes
collègues et je ne manquerai pas de le
relier à l'argile fait jamais mauvais
effet de le relayer de nombreux va
sortir un tout petit peu de l'hexagone
on le dit on le répète l'épidémie on
peut dire le mot voire pandémie elle est
devenue mondiale donc regarder cette
carte c'est quasiment l'ensemble de la
planète qui est touché à différents
degrés bien sûr dans les pays qui sont
en jaune tout très clair il ya moins de
100 cas parfois quelques à peine une
dizaine au delà de 5000 cas vous le
voyez en rouge
évidemment il ya la chine 79000 cas avec
déjà près de 3000 bord mort le
coronavirus avec 6 fait évidemment la
une la une de toute la presse mondiale
en tout cas européenne
comment elle traite 7,7 presse ce virus
est maladie cette épidémie ben alors
c'est depuis deux jours c'est clair et
net c'est la panique
et c'est surtout en europe chacun pour
soi c'est à se demander pourquoi une
espèce d'entité continental gens je ne
sais pas moi une union européenne
s'occuper de ça mais donc regarder à
l'italie depuis le plus touché en europe
et un débat justement en ce moment sur
la times baden savoie et donc la une de
la stampa
est-ce qu'il faut publier des données
tout si tout est ce que ça donne minuad
est fake news mais il ya aussi des
papiers un peu plus sur la liste par
exemple aujourd'hui sur la la magie du
silence de venise donc avec des images
jamais vues sur la place sa marque avec
60 points
en moins de touristes et de recel ab
givet les suisses viennent ce matin
d'interdire le salon de l'auto c'est un
truc énorme en terme d'économie donc pas
de salon de l'auto pas de salon de
l'horlogerie au mois d'avril non plus at
il décidé tout rassemblement de plus de
mille personnes ce matin et est interdit
en suisse sinon que font les suisses
font ce qu'ils font d'habitude dans ces
cas il se réfugie dans leurs huttes avec
les consignes gouvernementales c'est
assez amusant sur les trucs il faut
acheter avec alors du fromage des
médicaments des noix de la grèce de
l'huile 3 litres d'eau par personne et
surtout natürlich du chocolat voilà
medidas masse douglas des mesures plus
dures c'est ce que réclame ce matin la
presse espagnole avec un ministre de la
santé qui n'écarte pas l'idée de mieux
contrôler davantage toutes les
agglomérations touchées
l'allemagne l'allemagne qui vient de
mettre en quarantaine une ville au nord
du pays
c'est ça alors déjà en temps normal
journal populaire bild de lésine pas sur
les points d'exclamation là c'est encore
pire c'est la totale panique ni
personnes en quarantaine donc à arenberg
avec 14 cas diagnostiqués depuis deux
jours et surtout le journal le monde
pendant qu'on était en train de danser
de chanter habillé en clown dans le
carnaval combien d'entre nous allemands
avons été contaminés et itunes journal
me pose quand même la question de savoir
s'il faut devenir associé à les
incroyables en degrés ce qui est déjà
visiblement le cas en roumanie où j'ai
trouvé cette photo dans un journal à une
dame qui prend d'étranges mon dieu
extraordinaire attention l étouffement
bel et bien cru en arrêt cardiaque
la grande bretagne alors le corps au
navire russe a réussi quelque chose
d'inouï c'est à dire des quartiers d une
de la presse britannique toutes les
insultes à l'égard de bruxelles quoique
pas encore pour le moment qui disent que
ça vient de bruxelles
le telegraph va jusqu'à affirmer
aujourd'hui que le corona virus changera
le monde tel qu'on le connaît les belges
comme toujours c'est une excuse de
s'engueuler entre wallons et flamands
est-ce qu'il va y avoir enfin un vrai
gouvernement demande ce monsieur yoram
cohen cela collation corona et puis pour
finir sur les rangs jeudi sur une
trentaine d'autres pays mais pour finir
ce virologue aux pays bas où le premier
cas noté ce matin alors là c'est une
vraie catastrophe
est-ce qu'on va donc interdire cette
année l'eurovision parce que c'est à
rotterdam dont deux mois à voir des gens
qui viennent par tous même si c'est vrai
alors c'est sûr vous vraiment c'est
comme ça
al ghadir les césar vous êtes un fan
merci beaucoup alex pour cet or vu
presse européenne spécial quand un virus
malvy vous partiriez ronaldo a pris
rendez vous serez fier à la grille parce
que c'est vrai que la crise
je partirai rien venir au monde avec un
masque et puis voilà
bien sûr je vous ai rien venir demain
saint georges se soucie que la journée
maintenant je sais même pas ce que cela
va rejeter pas dans ma circonscription
prédictions des délais moi du tout parce
que j'ai peur c'est parce que si je
reviens y va on va me demander dans ses
14 jours chez moi j'en n'ai pas du tout
envie
bon allez vous avez envie de rester à
les assembler pour c est peut-être sur
les retraites et les systèmes henrichon
peloux hall 10 ans on parle des
retraites à présent si vous voulez bien
frédéric saldmann parce que le le
coronavirus n'a pas empêché le débat de
se poursuivre c'est le point retraite
tout de suite
et c'est un point retraite avec
stéphanie des pierres qui nous rejoint
dans un instant avec un échange qui a
marqué les discussions dans l'hémicycle
hier soir regarde au total il nous reste
trente mille 700 amendements
combien de sous-amendements ont été
porté à votre connaissance et est ce que
la proposition de loi que nous allons
examiner dans quelques moments va encore
retarder nos travaux ça fait trois jours
que ça dure
vous devriez au moins changer l'horaire
une fois passé 23 heures ça démarre la
machine se met en route et comme il faut
continuer accréditer la thèse d'un 49 3
eh bien on commence les injonctions
monsieur le président au secours dit
nous nous en sommes bons clairement ça
suffit réactualisé un peu la stratégie
le coach legendre entre le marquage en
défense les attaques du numéro 10
monsieur cazeneuve et à 23h le démarrage
des rappels au règlement sur le thème de
l'obstruction parlementaire
je vous suggère une petite
réactualisation de votre stratégie
voilà petit réactualisation de vos
stratégies on va en parler de cet
échange mais je salue l'arrivée de nos
joyeux chroniqueurs du vendredi
géraldine woessner du quotidien du
magazine le point
bertrand dicale qui va nous faire
chanter ses chansons fut qui font l'actu
de france info et camille saféris vous
allez découvrir les députés autrement
vous allez le voir
j'en suis sûr frédéric saldmann cette
séquence de quoi s'agit-il drôle c'est
drôle c'est un échange la france est
soumise accuse en fait la république en
marche de l'accusé en permanence
d'obstruction donc c'est à la réponse du
berger à la bergère
alors hier soir stéphanie nous nous
sommes laissés à l'article 2 du débat
sur les retraites
et qu'est ce que j'apprends ce soir on
en est à l'article 7 milles avant ce
débat ne faut jamais désespérer mais
rien mais on est donc à l'article 7 bon
rassurez vous il en reste 65 et encore
trente mille amendements mais les
députés débattent des militaires des
régimes spéciaux des fonctionnaires via
les discussions de fond des
accélérations et évidemment des temps
morts
l'opposition et la majorité reprennent
régulièrement leur valse à deux temps la
france insoumise et les communistes
cherchent à ralentir les débats
la république en marche dénoncent
l'obstruction c'est ce qu'on voyait dans
l'extrait
hier les communistes ont dégainé
nouvelles armes de procédures allez hop
25 minutes à ne pas parler du projet de
loi en lui-même mais la france insoumise
et les communistes prennent soin
d'alterner les coûts de tension à base
de procédure et les vraies questions de
fond car ils ne veulent pas à porter le
chapeau en cas de 49 3 c'est la bataille
de l'opinion qui se joue 1 / / / ce 49,3
rassurez-moi les insoumis ils ont ils
ont pas cessé de se faire entendre un
même s'il ya de la stratégie continue
l'obstruction bien sûr qu'il continue ce
matin ils ont fait trois rappels au
règlement d'affilée 3 en moins d'une
heure alors c'était en fait une passe
d'armes très politiques
la france insoumise n'était pas
convaincu par les justifications de
jacques maire alors jacques maire c'est
ce député de la majorité qui est
rapporteur d'une partie du projet de loi
jusqu'en 2012 il a travaillé pour
l'assureur axa il a d'ailleurs toujours
des actions à hauteur de 400 mille euros
départ qu'il avait mentionné dans sa
déclaration de patrimoine mais depuis le
début des discussions les insoumis
l'accusent de conflit d'intérêts il
estime que la réforme des retraites va
favoriser l'épargné individuelle donc
les assureurs donc le portefeuille du
rapporteur
alors jacques maire a demandé l'avis de
la sage de l'assemblée la déontologue
et ce matin il a lu sa réponse dans
l'hémicycle on va l'écouter mais y at-il
un conflit d'intérêt avec ma fonction de
rapporteur
sa réponse est clairement non elle en
conclut je cite vos intérêts aux
financiers financier au sein du groupe
axa ne vous interdisent pas d'exercer
les fonctions de rapporteur du titre 2
dès lors qu'aucune des dispositions de
ce titre ne concernent directement
l'épargne-retraite et que par conséquent
vos intérêts privés ne sont pas
susceptibles d'interférer avec vos
fonctions de rapporteur s'est mise au
point mise au point jacques maire peut
donc rester rapporteur mais pour couper
court à la polémique il dit qu'il ne
prendra pas part au vote sur trois
articles l'ailier donc à l'épargné
retraite
ça s'appelle se déporter alors c'est une
procédure prévue pour éviter qu'un
député soit juge et partie c'est une
procédure encore très peu utilisée
jacques maire est seulement le deuxième
à s'en servir officiellement les lois de
2013 et 2017 ont permis des avancées en
matière de lutte contre les conflits
d'intérêts sans éteindre
on le voit bien aujourd'hui tous les
débats sur la transparence marcy
stéphanie la suite et nos points
retraites continue la semaine prochaine
toujours pas
49 3 en vue on passe au bloc notes tout
de suite frédéric saldmann je suis sûr
que vous avez adoré nos chroniqueurs du
vendredi c'est géraldine woessner qui
commence avec le salon de l'agriculture
vous avez passé la semaine complète et
ce grand débat national lancé à cette
occasion un débat sur l'avenir de la pac
de la politique agricole commune mais ça
vous manquait un grand débat national
avec site internet des réunions
publiques 140 citoyens vont être tirés
au sort pour dessiner la stratégie
agricole du pays c'est un vrai challenge
il a été lancé cette semaine par la
présentatrice karine le marchand très
populaire d'amour il dans le pré vous
connaissez et attention il va y avoir
une opération inédite
c'est la première fois qu'on va
interroger les français sur
l'agriculture française vos points de
vue sur l'écologie la maltraitance
animale la place de l'agriculture
biologique en france les enjeux
écologiques sont énormes
donc il faut aussi qu'on fasse entendre
nos voix je ne sais pas si on va être
entendue mais au moins on aura essayé
bon alors là on ne parle pas vraiment à
pâques dans les tenants bien de
problèmes et c'est ce qui a ulcéré les
agriculteurs que j'ai croisé au salon
cette semaine ils comprennent pas à quoi
va servir ce débat sinon à mieux
comprendre les attentes de la société
mes enfants les connaître des gens elles
veulent la société elle veut moins de
pesticides moins de souffrance animale
des jolis paysages que tout le monde
soit bien payé ça on le veut tous sauf
que le l'objectif d'une politique
agricole
c'est pas ça c'est plutôt que tout le
monde est à manger à un prix abordable
est-ce qui est pas du tout dans le
collimateur de ceux qui estiment que bas
puisque la pax et leurs impôts ils ont
leur mot à dire en fait la pac c'est pas
une subvention aux agriculteurs c'est
une subvention à l'alimentation ça
compense le fait qu'on ne paye pas notre
nourriture à son juste prix ça
s'explique pour un tas de raisons
politiques économiques géostratégique
même mais ces raisons là on va pas les
comprendre en trois jours seulement et
c'est le temps qu'on va laisser avec les
experts un grand débat c'est l'occasion
de comprendre et d'apprendre non alors
évidemment il faut espérer que ce soit
l'occasion d'apprendre je suis allé
visiter le site internet de ce débat je
vous invite à le faire il est très bien
fait très content
les bourgs et d'information il ya deux
problèmes quand même je ne sais pas qui
va aller lire les 240 pages du projet de
diagnostic
rédigé par les experts et surtout il
manque quand même des informations
capitales pour connecter les thèmes je
prends un exemple concret les citoyens
ils vont devoir se prononcer sur les
priorités de la future pac à budget
constant voire moindres puisque la
grande bretagne va ça vient
et bah qu'est ce qu'on priorise le prix
des aliments les rendements l'export
moins de pesticides
si le sait moins de pesticides par
exemple nulle part il n'est écrit n'ont
aucun document que les rendements du blé
en bio c'est 50% de moins
nulle part ils vont pas des surcoûts
liés au matériel à la main d'oeuvre
donc c'est un peu démago bas et l'on se
dit s'ils choisissent ceux là la
conséquence c'est avec quoi on paye
parce que le budget actuel de la pac ne
suffira pas autre exemple la moitié de
la production en céréales françaises est
exportée elle nourrit notamment le nord
de l'afrique ont toutes une partie aussi
de ce qui reste ça va pour la nourriture
des animaux
donc si on décide demain que les aides
de la pac elles sont conditionnées à un
meilleur usage à moins d' usage de
pesticides à des règles
environnementales plus fort alors
accompagné les belles temps on va et de
mettre des moyens les marchés que
comment comment les l'afrique du nord
notamment pourra acheter dans les
productions
voilà un débat il suppose qu'ils soient
éclairés pour être utile je ne suis pas
certaine que ce soit le cas mauvais
point de géraldine woessner on va
chanter si vous voulez d'un frédéric
l'état fait bon pour la santé
déchanter et par rapport aux retraites
une question est ce que c'est bon pour
la santé la retraite c'est à vous de me
voir sur trois semaines de vacances on
perd un peu un point de quotient
intellectuel déjà dit pas à caen
s'interdit tard quand on laisse les
muscles repos il fonde à toute vitesse
si je place vos deux jambes pendant deux
mois ça fond c'est bien on est comme des
montres automatiques on se recharge aux
mouvements écouter alors on oublie div
et on fait activités et on reste
passionnée avec vous
bertrand vous parlez de nom de famille
cette semaine oui oui parce que vous
avez vu ce qu'il s'est passé en début de
semaine dans une réunion électorale
d'anne hidalgo
l'humoriste christophe alévêque afin
jeunes aux enjeux mot niveau maternelle
faut bien le dire
puis vint la buse agnès buzyn doit être
poursuivi par ce jeu de mots depuis sa
petite enfance
néanmoins ça n'a pas provoqué un vrai
scandale mais plutôt beaucoup de gènes
de tous les côtés y compris du donc dans
le camp de la maire de paris parce que
se moquer du nom d'un responsable
politique c'est quand même quelque chose
qu'on ne fait pas surtout pas au micro
surtout pas quand on est proche de
l'oreille du responsable politique en
question ou de ses partisans dont dans
en public parce qu'on glisse qu'une
réplique symétrique parce qu'il n'y a à
peu près aucun nom en france aucun nom
patronymique qui ne puisse être victime
d'un k danse est sûre on va aller boire
un an qu'à moi pour ça que c'est quand
même rare dans la chanson et dans la
culture populaire qu'on s'amuse avec le
nom d'un responsable politique
mais myriam vous êtes certainement bien
trop jeune mais surtout trop éloignés de
la culture de l'ultra gauche pour
connaître une des rares exceptions la
scène de pratiquer l'art
cela date de 1972 écoutez
[Musique]
une sublime france pas
c'est joe jonas
vous avez bonne mémoire jean jonas
c'était un un militant de la fédération
anarchiste en même temps qu'ils aient
des chanteurs de variété et en 72
georges pompidou et président de la
république et il fait cette chanson pont
pie peut pomper que dalle qui est une
chanson qui attaquent pompidou l'homme
le système la vème république la france
les français tout ça mais c'est une
exception dans la chance parce que dans
la chanson quand on s'amuse avec le nom
de famille de quelqu'un c'est pour en
faire un usage pour un usage positif le
calembour n'est pas un calembour ils
n'attaquent pas c'est un trône et on a
un exemple
évidemment avec france gall sur un texte
admiratif et habile de michel berger
[Musique]
là
hélas pour l acide quéral et oui
évidemment ella fitzgerald alors bon
c'est vraiment tout ça c'est un jeu de
mots tout simples un niveau cm1 lui
aussi est là là mais c'était quand même
sorti en 1987 beaucoup des auditeurs de
france gall se sont dit mais qui est
cette est là mais c'est la fille de
jarrat lisons h une compilation ils ont
découvert l'oeuvre d'une des plus
grandes voix de l'histoire du jazz
et c'est pour ça finalement que de temps
en temps les calembours sont
intéressants mais en général
jouer avec les noms de famille c'est
quand même à la première personne que ça
se fait le mieux c'est l'axé le plus
facile le plus admis mais aussi le plus
efficace écoutez
ouais c'est moi
combien de gainsbourg gainsbarre ya le
nom est normal là bas il est devenu dû
quitter
les gens véridique génial pour ça moi
j'ai toujours connu personnellement ya
du beau monde
et oui nougaro new york ça fait nous
d'ailleurs gainsbourg qui devient
gainsbarre et donc symétriquement
renault qui devient renard et puis ce
jeu de mots improbables sa légende est
véridique dick medicrea méchante c'est
un texte de mickaël furnon de mickey 3d
ça nous confirme bien que si on veut
faire des calembours sur les noms de
famille et pour que ceux ci soient
vraiment à nous qu'il soit vraiment
reconnu bas il faut que ce soit ni même
qu'il ait faisions par le passé hier on
termine avec vos caméras prendre un
verre avec lit avec là aujourd'hui
elodie jeu qui la forge c'est une député
modem de l'isère elle est très concernés
par la pénibilité du travail mais mais
celle des députés en fait donc elle
serait elle s'est intéressée à la haye
la ouvrait pour la fin de séance de nuit
à l'assemblée étaient envoyés à des
traits elle trouve que les journées sont
longues surtout en ce moment et puis
qu'on se couche tard et c'est vrai qu'en
ce moment ce constat alors l affaire
notamment voté un texte pour la
suppression des emplois familiaux
samassa va en avoir excusé avant
l'interdiction d'engager des membres de
sa famille comme collaborateur on
connaît bien le sujet mais alors est-ce
que c'est pas un peu dommage finalement
admettons qu'on est vraiment quelqu'un
dans sa famille soient hyper compétent
mais on peut pas ne pas l'engager parce
que c'est là où par exemple vous êtes
personnes à votre famille de compétent
non c'est dommage mais j'ai embauché
personnes de ma famille non plus c'est
vrai dans les yeux attention si vous
allez sur le site de l'assemblée
j'avais le nombre des collaborateurs
donc fait enfin jeu même si on joue pas
sur le jeu pareil bonjour moi ça ou
alors il faudrait pas être très vous les
ch'ti côté un peu bah oui c'est simple 3
6 2 alors elodie jacquet laforge elle a
toujours une tenue différente au
perchoir c'est très marrant parce que l
à d'incroyables changements d'où parfois
la une une veste strict une veste verte
une veste rouge avec le chemisier blanc
même le perfecto un parfois et alors on
se demande finalement si elle n'est pas
un peu une sorte de
harbi député regarder passer ce que vous
verrez que j'ai toujours le même
perfecto la même veste orange ça tourne
c'est à dire qu'il faut quand même laver
les vêtements c'est ça enfin après
chacun là où chacun fait comme il veut
vous n'êtes pas comme les grands comme
souvent les actrices de cinéma qui sont
prêts étaient détenus pour aller dans
une soirée pour l'instant gala je fais
donc un appel ce qui voudrait abriter
des tenues d'accord sachant qu'il faut
quand même tenue de travail
alors évidemment question rituelle tous
les députés ont un hobby on le sait une
passion un loisir pour se vider la tête
donc là depuis le début de la saison n'a
eu celui qui avait la cabane dans les
arbres
celle qui fait de la chorale celui qui
aime se déguiser en tortues ninja sauf
dégradation alors que j'ai évidemment
posé la question rituelle aller le dit
jacques et la forge quel est son hobby
est alors moi j'adore la brocante
ouais alors l'avantagé c'est que je peux
en plus concilier ça avec mes activités
de parlementaires donc parce que
beaucoup de vieilleries à l'assemblée
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
manifestations à locale la foire aux
chèvres de cintheaux je suis invité par
le maire ont fait un petit discours il
ya le préfet qui est là alors qu'est ce
que vous aimez particulièrement j'avais
fait une petite fixation sur les
tableaux de fleurs de natures mortes
quoi voilà mais après je suis fan
d'assiettes de verre enfin je sens que
des choses un peu de mamie quand même
mais doit être m a mis mon meilleur pote
ed si j'en trouverai une ambre encore je
sais pas comme j'ai plus les miennes ah
oui voilà mais vous êtes incroyables
dans cet exercice là non vous êtes
trouvé avait réussi quelque chose il
fallait attendre cette émission
dominique amis mais voilà bien quelque
chose de sa merci beaucoup frédéric
saldmann d'être venu sur le plateau des
cpge rappel le titre de votre truc
on n'est jamais mieux soigner que par
soi-même quel titre en ces temps de
coronavirus merci les amis à vendredi
prochain c'est le week end profitez bien
à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]